- We'll take five suggestions
and then we'll do this.
You put a hand up, which is so polite.
I love it. Yeah.
I love it, you're like,
at hip hop concerts, what do they say?
Put your hands up. Yes, I'll do that."
Hello. What would you like a rap about?
- [Female Audience Member] Vaginas.
- Vaginas? Cool. That's a
very broad topic, obviously.
That's not a criticism
of the size of vaginas.
That was a misspoken sentence there.
Vaginas. Very broad, but
let's be more specific.
Let's hone in.
Let's, you know, like the
effects of cranberry juice
on a vagina or, you know, mismatched labia
and how that's perfectly normal
and not something to be worried about.
But not those, cause I've
already suggested them.
(audience laughing)
There are so many topics
to do with vaginas.
You can trust me. It's not like a test,
don't be like, I don't think you'll know
anything about this.
No, go for it.
- [Female Audience Member]
I don't know! Ummm...
- Someone else can help
you out if you want.
- [Female Audience
Member #2] Hairy vagina!
- What was that?
- [Female Audience Member #2] Hairy!
- A hairy vagina? Lovely.
A voluptuous, follicular vagina.
- [Female Audience Member]
I was gonna say that
but I didn't want to say it out loud.
- You were going to say that
but you didn't want to say it-
you could've mimed it.
There you go. That would have been fine.
So, a hairy vagina. Lovely.
That's a great first
suggestion for a Sunday.
You absolute animals.
If you're in the kind of
these little tables here.
- [Male Audience Member]
Storming of Old Trafford.
- The storming of Old Trafford.
That sounds like a battle
from a thousand years ago.
But what happened today?
Manchester United were
due to play Liverpool
in the Northwest Darby and a
lot of Manchester United fans
occupied the pitch and
they had to postpone
and then later call off the game.
And I, I imagine like
you, sir, was very annoyed
cause I was quite looking forward to it,
and I did get up in time for the kick-off.
There we go. No one else
is going to enjoy that bit.
But hairy vaginas and the
storming of Old Trafford.
Middle of the room, if
you're in this kind of area,
what do you wanna rap about?
- [Female Audience
Member #3] Aliens playing
virtual reality.
- You said aliens playing
virtual reality. I like that.
Thank you. Someone over there
that made a kind of expression
as if to speak, what were you gonna say?
- [Male Audience Member #2]
Internal combustion engine.
- Internal combustion engine. Yeah.
Do you have a particular
vehicle that you want that in?
- [Male Audience Member #2] Aston Martin.
- An Aston Martin. Great. Okay.
And then people over here,
what you want to hear a rap about?
- [Male Audience Member #3] Stinky balls.
- Stinky balls, good.
(audience laughing)
- This then, lovely
people, is gonna be a rap,
a freestyle rap made up on the spot
based entirely on those suggestions.
If we can drop that beat, good sir,
that'd be delightful.
The storming of Old
Trafford, a hairy vagina,
an internal combustion engine,
aliens in virtual
reality, and stinky balls.
We able to press play on that track?
(music begins)
- Yes. And do not worry, guys.
It will not be anywhere
near as atrociously,
embarrassingly, toe-curlingly
bad as you're expecting
a privately educated middle-class
white British boy to be.
I'm very excited to end the show this way.
Even if all of you seem
totally unconvinced,
this is gonna be great.
We'll start off with that one
because I think that's the
one you know least about.
Okay.
♪ You got to trust the
facts I'm spitting. ♪
♪ I hope you won't believe ♪
♪ 149 years ago Newton Heath ♪
♪ was the name of a team
built by a foundry. ♪
♪ Now in the present, 2021. ♪
♪ The Glazers, that's American family. ♪
♪ They came and they
thought they'd be handy ♪
♪ using all the financials, but
they drew out all the profit ♪
♪ and people now they're sick,
to the hind they say stop it. ♪
♪ You need to back off. ♪
♪ So they went on the pitch,
on the hallowed turf, ♪
♪ they broke through the
turnstiles by the dressing room. ♪
♪ We couldn't get football
in the afternoon. ♪
♪ That one guy's nodding,
he's feeling the shorts, ♪
♪ saying yeah, he really nailed
the storming of Old Trafford ♪
♪ It only happened today. ♪
♪ This was meant to be
between you and me, ♪
♪ a topic so contemporary,
but that's okay. ♪
♪ Maybe it's just in my mind,
I got an oculus quest, ♪
♪ I use it to unwind. ♪
♪ Put it on my head. ♪
♪ My eyes look like a
car, like I'm driving ♪
♪ when I'm in the VR. ♪
♪ I'm not saying I'm an
alien, I'm a homosapien. ♪
♪ But if I go out to outer
space I'll be facing them ♪
♪ and saying, guys, you
want to do this a favor. ♪
♪ You can get controllers
and play beat saber. ♪
♪ They'd be blown away. ♪
♪ They're like my gosh,
this is really great. ♪
♪ I want to buy VR. ♪
♪ I say other things to
their little green face, ♪
♪ You could pretend you're in the car ♪
♪ In first place in a race. ♪
♪ They're like, wow,
I'm really starving, ♪
♪ for the experience of Aston Martin. ♪
♪ Driving. Chris, can you
give me some instruction? ♪
♪ Cause they don't understand
internal combustion. ♪
♪ They use magnets. They
use nuclear power. ♪
♪ But if you've got a little time, ♪
♪ let me break it down for you. ♪
♪ In the fifties, Martins
were on the freeways, ♪
♪ Everybody starting,
used to use a crank ♪
♪ about 30 years before, ♪
♪ but if you pop the hood
inside then you would've saw, ♪
♪ a little piston set going all around. ♪
♪ But if you're in Germany,
they don't use the pound. ♪
♪ They use the Euro. ♪
♪ They have a Wankel rotary engine, ♪
♪ it's different slightly, ♪
♪ well I really should mention. ♪
♪ Always uses the spark from the plugs. ♪
♪ I know this is not what you expect ♪
♪ from this dog, from the UK. ♪
♪ You're like, all right, me old China, ♪
♪ Rap about that that hairy vagina. ♪
♪ Of course I will. It
doesn't matter if it's long. ♪
♪ If it's like the Amazon
forest with all of the frogs. ♪
♪ Well, if there's crabs or
other animals in there, ♪
♪ my main advice would be
to shave off your hair. ♪
♪ I say, please guys,
trim it down this time. ♪
♪ Maybe get a reference
from your OBGY...N. ♪
♪ It doesn't matter if it's
shaved or it's waxed. ♪
♪ If it's coming out your
fly when you open it a bit. ♪
♪ Is creeping out there like
the tendrils of the ivy ♪
♪ whether it be hairy,
whether it be shiny. ♪
♪ I don't mind, even if
it's a little bit smelly, ♪
♪ even if it's sweaty after
you've been doing ballet. ♪
♪ But one thing that always appalls me, ♪
♪ if I'm at a urinal, if I'm in a store, ♪
♪ see a guy next to me
and I'm like, yo, yo, ♪
♪ you need to get some wipes
on the side of your balls. ♪
♪ Why they so smelly?
What is all the scent? ♪
♪ It's really horrible. ♪
♪ And the guy, I know I meant well, ♪
♪ saying he should take a
shower more frequently. ♪
♪ Why? Cause there's little dick cheese ♪
♪ and it's seeping free out of the side. ♪
♪ He's got to use the shower gel. ♪
♪ Why? Cause his balls, they be
smelling up to high heaven. ♪
♪ High hell, it smells
something satanic. ♪
♪ That's a freestyle rap, I hope
all of y'all understand it. ♪
♪ We didn't plan it and it
started with a football ♪
♪ And ended over there with
the horrible stinky balls. ♪
(audience cheering)
Thank you very much,
you guys are delightful.